he's Bill Hader who was kind enough to
stay around after fritzy nearly blew it
Bill Hader stars in it chapter 2 opens
in theaters this Friday stars as Barry
in the HBO comedy which was nominated
for 17 Emmys
I didn't buy into Barry originally yeah
no yeah a lot of people didn't I just I
kept saying there's no way he can be a
serial killer
right or a hitman I guess he is a serial
killer because I think if you kill more
than one person you're a serial killer
oh is that what the definition is but
but what did you need to learn about
being a serial killer to play that role
the right thing I think it was more of
just the feeling lonely and and wanting
a community that that kind of thing and
then to make it interesting we made him
a murderer when you pitch this do you
pitch it with a straight face yeah yeah
yeah yeah we went to HBO and say I
wanted to a movie a TV show about a
hitman who wants to be an actor and they
just started throwing money at us and
and as you know I've told you the
Chechnya --nz they steal oh yeah just
about every scene that they're on my
gosh ya know Hank and yeah yeah he's one
of the nicest guys in the world Anthony
Kerrigan but most of the stuff in season
two he was coming up with on his own I
mean he would improvise
oh you some of those things like we
would write a lot of them but then other
ones he would just come up with in the
moment and we were like oh can you
please say that again I laughed and we
had Henry Winkler in less than a year
ago it and he just you could see in his
face how important this is to almost
have that resurgent and people may not
remember how big he was in the 70
massive and then he came in and read for
us like that was crazy walking in and
there's all these actors to read Kusano
and there's Henry Winkler just with his
script ready to do and I went into
casting director Sherry Thomas I was
like Henry Winkler's out there I have to
read with anyway and Alec and I were all
peeking out looking at him and he's just
the sweetest man in the world do you
think he could be a serial killer I
don't you know what I don't want to
think about that no and
because you when the answers yes yeah no
no I know it's weird even doing those
scenes with the guns and stuff I just
don't like it yeah I'm like not someone
cuz everyone's like oh is that fun doing
it and it's like no the minute we shoot
I'm kind of like cotton all right they
had a dare to cut around me in the pilot
I shoot this car and Alec Berg when we
got to go again was great and he played
it back but dark comedy yeah are you
attracted to dark humor yeah yeah like
you know and like dr. Strangelove was a
movie I loved growing up and and and you
know all those types of yeah III do like
I like that aspect of playing something
very straight and then just the insanity
of the situation you just played totally
real you know comedians have talked
about you know Eddie Murphy was on with
Jerry Seinfeld comedians and cars and
and he was talking about using that part
of your brain the comedic part of it
they it's a muscle and I don't know if
you've ever gone through that where like
you can't constantly have to keep
thinking that way I do you do you
understand what Eddie Kazan he said he's
nervous about stand-up because it hasn't
used that part of his brain yeah maybe I
mean some of its just kind of you know
you natural you know you see people like
Will Forte will say the funniest thing
or Fred Armisen or Kristen Wiig or and
these people say hilarious things and
then they they almost look at you like
they don't understand why you're
laughing you know cuz to them it's like
it's funny but it's like yeah I have
these thoughts all the time why is that
weird to you you know but uh I yeah I
mean sometimes you just can't help it
and so yeah I haven't had that but you
know maybe I will they get a little
older are you fun to go out to dinner
with yeah sometimes yeah yeah sometimes
they can yeah I I tend to in new
situations I tend to be on a little bit
more because I'm nervous okay so it's
kind of a way of I especially in it too
when i we were first day of shooting was
this big dinner scene and
was cracking jokes the entire time
because I was super nervous why cuz
you're just around all the you know
Jessica Chastain James McAvoy it's a new
crew it's a horror movie it's this giant
movie and you're just going like I hope
you know I do well in this and so you
you it's a it's almost a way of failing
quick cuz a lot of your jokes don't work
you know so it's like okay let me bomb
in front of you guys so I can relax a
little bit even though they're probably
going this guy's not that funny yeah no
that's good they don't find me funny
alright alright I bombed I got that over
with now I can relax and do my job
do non funny people try to make you
laugh yeah all the time yeah do they
want to try to oh yeah yeah the were not
the worst but it's weird when people try
to do like voices and stuff around me or
impressions and you just go oh don't
that's right it's okay that's not what
Nicholas Cage sounds like we did those
for Jay Pharoah oh really
we went around the room and I don't know
I know exactly but it was funny because
it was awkward yeah like fritzy will do
Prince he's pretty good at some
impersonations alright ok ok here here
we go he's lightning and crap
thunderkick I say you can't win burgess
Meredith rocky yeah alright okay Wow Wow
okay you didn't leave all right that was
good now that you explained it to me it
was great okay I'm the greatest fighter
in the world no one could beat mom
that's good that's good he's hot need
his children praised be Allah are you
being nice no that is good okay it is
good Oh Marge Simpson hey Bill hey
there's some studio and that's pretty
cool how'd you get him on the channel
well you know it's the Seaton do you do
an impersonation not in front of Bill
Hader I bomb no this is good all the
time see cuz I'm was feeling
okay he did it come on come on fritzy
didn't uh I know what impressions do I
do
brett farr i do one word impressions
impressions are one more impression
brett favre he says anything that
somebody asks him he just repeats it
back to them and says of course okay
that's the four slap on Martin's shirt
one time cuz Martin Short sometimes
we'll just be like we'll say somebody
and he'll just throw it out at me like
you know and one time someone said Fred
Gwynne he goes bill do frequent but you
had are you doing Herman Munster yeah
yeah yeah yeah I just have to quickly do
something but then you did Martin Short
there too yeah and the people do it
Polly I don't think you do
impersonations do you no not not now no
no you can do it Andrew Luck okay that's
good yeah there's nothing else to it
that's good thank you he's being polite
McLovin you don't do one do sure don't
okay I mean I could just get my general
British no no no that's not good that's
not good
do you wish shut up shut up don't
embarrass me okay the last time you were
on here we go
oh you did Keith Morrison oh yeah okay
now Fritzi I think was maybe
overreacting to this now listen here we
go the guy he the guy he shot me shot
you a dirty look see I told you it's
just a little too much there do you know
Josh mankiewicz that guy in Dateline he
always does a thing where someone will
say he always sounds like he's got a
stuffy nose one he always has a cold and
he's always in the Bahamas like any time
if someone's murdered
something in a tropical place always in
Hawaiian shirt but he always will say in
everyone you can do a drinking game and
he'll be like now most people when they
find their their their wife dead they
call 9-1-1 oh my god and then yeah
Dennis Murphy's you're the one that he
always gets ones that are like like it's
always high school kids and he's this
guy he's like yeah they're BFFs you know
they're lol's quickly turned to WTF s
when they found their wife yeah he
sounds a hundred while trying to say
exactly yeah he's like they were using
snapchat Jay Ferrel will you know embody
the person yeah rock and dust the hands
that's like the fingers the whole thing
yeah you don't think you don't know now
my mind's like I have to kind of listen
to it and tune like yeah get in tune or
something I'm not like Jay Jay I
remember when he first came in he just
started doing people you started doing
impressions at the table and I was whoa
how do you how do you do that you know
he's yeah he's something else
when's the last what's the last voice
that you kind of mastered oh man I don't
remember are you doing less of it now
yeah I don't really like I mean I mean I
was just for Saturn alive so I don't
really do it just in my spare time is my
chore but I do watch you know yeah I'll
watch something like Dateline and then
walk around going like just to like make
myself laugh
the last one I had to do I remember on
SNL was Alan Alda that was the one they
had to like figure out how to do but it
was just random cheaper random yeah but
it was just yeah that was hard yeah just
like that I forget it was him
auditioning for Biff and Back to the
Future II and let you how did you make
like a tree and get Eddie
when you were around Schwarzenegger
weren't you as a PA yeah are you
listening to his voice no no there is so
much else going on can you tell one good
story yeah he would he would make you
made he's talking about schnitzel Mike
we were out in the middle of the jungle
shooting this movie collateral damage
and he would go you know this is where
we shall pray today I am was I would
have schnitzel flown in for the cast and
crew I know I am there just be a long
pause and go Carl Weathers he ate it
[Laughter]
Jesse Ventura he ate the schnitzel just
then just all this punctuated with this
jungle sense and me sitting there
terrified predator and everybody who ate
schnitzel and I was like John I don't
think he's even talking to me I think
he's just kind of having a moment yeah
yeah I have very little interaction with
him it was kind of you know I was the
guy who was like hey Arnold they're
ready for you you know deidre you get
recruited to do it yeah VIN Wolff are
the guy the young actor who played
Ritchie in the original in the first
movie because this the sequel is all the
all the original kids now grown up as
adults and they have to fight the clown
again and and he he they said who do you
want to play you in the sequel and he
said me
then it worked yeah they called me and
yeah he's super powerful yeah yeah he's
super powerful and I just walked in you
know an Andy machete the director is a
wonderful guy said things like Sophie
and wants you in the movie okay so
you're in the movie is there is there
humor oh yeah yeah that's really funny
I'm actually in a nice spot where I'm
actually the me and this guy James
Ransone or we play Eddie and and Ritchie
and we're kind of the comic relief in
the movie so when it's a really scary
tense movie being the comic relief guys
or it's a good spot but do you get
different scripts now because of Barry
it's so funny the whole weight you know
typecasting is real anytime I do
something yeah I do it's it's whatever
the thing I did last that's right you
know so I did super bad it was like so
in this one you're a crazy cop you
realize how many scriptures crazy cops
you know and then yeah what Barry it's
kind of oh he's a vet who's kind of you
know sad you know or someone who's a
criminal who's trying to get his life
back on track or whatever and I'm like
I'm doing this on a show you know what
is what's your favorite story from super
bad man well there's a couple with
academe McLovin the kid who made my club
the kid played McLovin Christmas plaid
that's how he got his nickname because
he looks like he could yeah his dad or a
relative he was very sweet and but very
kind of like naive he was very young and
Seth Rogen and and Jonah Hill and I were
we said something and we said oh number
5 is alive and he was like wait what's
that but and then go short-circuit and
he goes with short circuit and we all it
was like in unison we all just like had
the same thought I go oh it's this
documentary about a this robot that
comes to life and we told him that
short-circuit was a serious documentary
he's like oh really yeah yeah it's with
this robot that um this guy may involve
on and then Seth Rogen's Lee yes Steve
Guttenberg stopped being an actor
and became a scientist and Fisher
Stevens and we like we just said it was
a super serious movie like a documentary
and he for like a year believe this
did you see the greatness in Jonah Hill
oh yeah all those guys he and Michael
Cera and Emma Stone I know I mean it was
I remember the first time I saw that
movie was the first time I had ever seen
myself on screen and I went to AB
advance screen of Superbad and I sat in
the back with Emma Stone and her mom and
we just sat there and watched the movie
and it was a college crowd and they went
nuts and we were just looking at each
other going can you believe we're in a
movie we know this is crazy but how
weird is that it's one thing to watch
yourself on TV yeah when you're larger
than life on his very strong and you're
with people watching you yeah
well I just had this at the it to
premiere where I watched it and there's
a moment in the movie where my character
is in peril and there was a guy across
the aisle I mean he looks like so he's
about to die horror movies scary movies
the crowd always gets into yeah they go
oh my favorite thing I ever heard it was
my friend told me that he went to go see
the Elephant Man remember that movie
yeah and he said the John at the end of
them was towards the end of the movie
and there's a moment was a very quiet
moment where Elephant Man is is talking
to this young woman and it's like she's
recognizing him as a human and it's a
very sweet moment and some guy in the
theater went it's called it chapter 2
which opens in theaters this Friday and
stars Bill Hader well do star eye
co-star big is a big in some okay yeah
but you star in Barry yes yeah you do do
star yeah you get top billing in that
yeah and season 3 will be I started
writing it next week okay yeah you don't
say
I know I'm never excited now I have to
go in and stare at a empty whiteboard
and just be like oh god what have we
gotten ourselves into uh Congrats on all
the Emmy nominations thanks man and
awards that's the girl
yeah thanks man he's a bill hater always
great to see you bill thank yous how
thanks right thank you
four more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]